You've probably heard China's claim to
the South China Sea as ancient.
That is a myth. This 1947 map started at
all. These few dashes
drawn over 70 years ago
have become one of the most dangerous
flesh points on the
planet. This single document now
dictates the flow of trillions in trade
and has sparked a
geopolitical firestorm. It's 1947,
in the chaos after World War II, the
Republic of China
publishes a map with a U-shaped
11-line claiming most of the South China
Sea, including the
Paracel and Spratly Islands.
At the time, the world barely noticed.
Colonial empires were falling and new
nations were emerging.
A vague line on a map from a government
fighting a civil war wasn't a priority.
It had no precise coordinates and no
clear legal explanation. That ambiguity
ignored at first became the root of a
massive international conflict.
In 1949, the Communists won the Chinese
Civil War. Mao Zedong's New
People's Republic of China
adopted the 11-dash map. But in 1952, the
PRC government made a critical change.
As a gesture to its Communist allies in
North Vietnam, it removed
the two dashes in the Gulf
of Tonkin. The 11-dash line became the
9-dash line. This proves
the line was never a fixed
ancient claim. It was politically
flexible, based on modern
politics, not ancient history.
Some modern Chinese maps even include a
10-dash east of Taiwan.
For decades, the line was just a symbol
on paper. That all changed in 2009.
In 2009, China submitted the map with its
9-dash line to the United Nations,
turning a dormant line
into an official challenge to the
international order. Neighboring
countries like the Philippines,
Vietnam, Malaysia, and Brunei saw their
own legally recognized maritime rights
directly threatened.
The Philippines fought back, not with
warships, but with lawyers. They took
China to an international
tribunal under the UN Convention on the
Laws of the Sea. In 2016,
the tribunal delivered a
landmark ruling. It declared that China's
claims of historic rights
inside the 9-dash line had no
legal basis. But China's response was
swift and absolute. It
rejected the ruling, calling it
"nothing but a piece of waste paper."
Today, we are living with the
fallout. A third of all global
shipping worth trillions of dollars
passes through the South China Sea
annually. To enforce its claim,
China has built artificial islands on
reefs and militarized
them with runways and missile
systems. They block and ram Philippine
supply boats and use water
cannons against Vietnamese
fishing vessels, all to enforce a line
that international law
has invalidated. This isn't
just regional squabble, it's a global
issue pitting China's
ambitions against international law.
The United Nations and its allies now
regularly conduct freedom
of navigation operations,
turning the waterway into a stage for a
great power competition.
If this breakdown of how
historical myths shape modern conflicts
is valuable to you,
hit that subscribe button
and like this video. It helps me make
content that cuts through all the
propaganda. That line
from 1947, a product of post-war
nationalism, has morphed
into the single biggest point of
tension in Asia. It started with 11
dashes, was trimmed to
9 for political reasons,
and is now a symbol of a nation's drive
to reclaim what it sees as its territory,
regardless of international law. The core
question remains unanswered,
and it gets more urgent every
day. Will the future of this vital
waterway be decided by
internationally agreed upon laws,
or by the will of the most powerful
nation in the region? The answer will
shape the 21st century.